[Musique]
ronin désert c'est vraiment votre
semaine parce que vous avez renforcer le
grand prix la danse 2020 c'est une
bourse avec un autre prix 35 dollars
votre projet doute qu elle voit jour
sous forme d'escale sur ici art et vie
vraiment vous avancez à grande vitesse
j'avance
oui il n'y a pas eu de plusieurs pas de
géant qui viennent de se faire cette
semaine mais c'est du travail de longue
haleine est loin des téléréalités ma
réalité arrivée rencontre l'actualité
aujourd'hui est de recevoir le grand
prix c'est c'était inimaginable pour moi
ça me donne le souffle pour continuer ça
me dit tu es raison finalement de
prendre la chose d'à côté et à toutes
ces fois où je me suis dis je quitte le
milieu
j'en ai assez de défendre mes oeuvres
pour qu'elles puissent juste avoir une
place sur les scènes ici au québec il
est chorégraphe danseuse archéologues en
quelque sorte de la culture votre projet
force et d'autres 2013 puis un beau duel
en 2015 a fait l'histoire si vous partez
à la recherche de beaux racines ça
commence en haïti terre de vos parents
qu'est-ce que vous avez découvert en
haïti je me suis rencontrés sur la tête
dans ce bouillon de culture est aussi
l'entente les gens à côté de moi qui
parle et qui dénonce des situations en
haïti
c'est ça finalement la création donc
j'étais la rencontre louis de mon
identité mais à la rencontre de quesques
à la création
vous y passerez
ça me fait du bien on voudrait être
découvrir grâce mais ça fait du bien
mais si aussi chambre là c'est
extrêmement chamblanc les escales
culturelles et je le dis toujours c'est
beau qui est ce qui en résulte
actuellement mais derrière l'image
beaucoup beaucoup de chamboulements
intérieur d'être confronté pour tous les
jours aux réalités et aux difficultés
que vivent mes différentes communes ou
les communautés noires mais surtout
haïti j'ai été expulsé du pays parce que
c'est l'ouragan matthew ce qui m'a mis
hors du pays mais ça m'a mis aussi hors
de moi que de constater que j'ai le luxe
de revenir dans la websérie sur tou.tv
vous attendu à halifax pour parler
d'esclavagé c'est que ce probable j'ai
appris énormément j'ai appris tout ce
que je ne savais pas dans les livres
d'histoire mais déjà que la ségrégation
au canada la dernière école à avoir été
desserrée guise en 1983
c'est ça a été un choc pour moi et en
mettant en lumière c'est vrai que c'est
plus agréable de la prendre pour
personne peu importe sa culture et je
pense que peu importe nos origines
quand on réalise qu à mon double clin
d'oeil il ya eu la ségrégation dans les
écoles et eu des gens qui devaient
marcher et traverser des personnes qui
leur envoyer des messages peu très peu
très positif il ya eu ces images qu'on
nous on place aux états unis qu'on place
au brésil complète en haïti ici dans ce
confort canadien il ya eu des gens qui
ont été déracinés de leur maison qui se
sont fait déménager leurs outils leurs
éléments les plus précieux dans des
camions poubelles
mais non mais moi moi qui vit à montréal
je ne peux même pas pensé qu'un jour un
camion poubelle près déménager
chose est arrivée à halifax vous êtes
diplômé en communication et en marketing
de l'université montréal militantes ou
si des fois c'est difficile de prendre
parole mais c'est difficile quand c'est
le chaos
c'est extrêmement risqué que de prendre
parole parce que un faux pas et le tout
bien tombé et en tant que le graff
moi je peux me permettre non pus faible
a personne qui puisse être permettre
mais toute ma réputation se bâtit
justement sur ma réputation sur
malheureusement mais sur mon image et je
pense que c'est lorsque le boat show
elle vient amener un peu plus de poids
qui met être grave c'est que juste à
temps dans un studio d'un rêvé de faire
des mouvements s'est exclamé le présent
rassembler le futur construire à partir
de tous toutes ces bribes d'informations
qui ont été fragmentée et essayer de
faire du beau mais de mettre en lumière
et d'espérer que les futures générations
accueille cette vibration de
[Musique]
dr j'espère que les conversations comme
si j'en avais encore plein donc merci
qui merci
[Musique]